montrer la transmission de l'antique sur
le moderne c'est le but de l'exposition
vivre à l'antique de marie antoinette à
napoléon 1er une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
datant de 1780 à 1815
ils sont présentés le but de
l'exposition vivre à l'antique de marie
antoinette est impoli ont promis et de
montrer l'importance de la redécouverte
de l'antiquité à la fin du xviiie siècle
et au début du 19e siècle et toutes les
répercussions que cela a pu avoir dans
la vie quotidienne comme dans le domaine
artistique ou voire sociale
l'exposition met en avant deux espaces
en particulier la salle de bain de
napoléon ainsi que la laiterie de
marie-antoinette point du départ de
l'expo était vraiment deux espaces phare
dans le dans ce domaine qui est la
laiterie de la reine que vous voyez ici
et la salle de bains de la paire eur ces
deux espaces où on essaie de recréer le
monde antique dans une sortie sphère
intime des souvent et donc avec l'expo
on voulait comprendre mieux pourquoi et
comment
au fin du xviiie siècle ils ont commencé
à remercier les présents à l'image du
passé lointain sur place tableaux
maquettes porcelaine de sèvres
l'exposition à bénéficier du prêt d'un
panorama de la ville de rome
l'exposition permettra au public de voir
de nombreuses maquettes de monuments
antiques qui ont été réalisés au xviiie
siècle des peintures quelques sculptures
des éléments en porcelaine également
produites par la manufacture de sèvres
principalement quelques oeuvres de
l'antiquité également je pense à un vase
assez monumentale issus de fouilles
archéologiques quelques éléments de
mobilier de décors intérieurs qui datent
de cette époque également l'exposition
va durer trois mois et sera disponible
jusqu'au 9 août